[Music]
hello conan o'brien again i asked you
for questions and man did you have
questions over 5 000 questions i chose
one at random here it is it's from lance
pelletier here's the question conan you
probably were able to try a lot of crazy
sandwiches on all your time off what
kind of sandwiches did you eat and which
one was your favorite that's a great
question i did have a lot of time off i
love sandwiches and i started making my
own and man lance did i come up with a
doozy check it out you start out with a
whole loaf of bread that's important
okay get processed ham and processed
turkey don't use the real stuff it's the
processing that makes it healthy and
then slobber it right on that sandwich
don't be shy
i like a lot of meat on my sandwich if
you don't know what i mean sounds dirty
but it doesn't really mean anything i
like mayo so really put some mayo on
there okay
then
check this out here's where we get fancy
salsa okay it's time to go south of the
border with a little salsa
and i had a little mexican cheese right
there
gravy gotta have gravy um
ah
very nice
fiber is important so i add flax plus
all right put a little fiber in there
you want this thing to move through you
like grain through a goose
then
i add a few chicken mcnuggets right here
because everybody loves chicken
mcnuggets kids love them and you push
them right in and the gravy holds them
okay that's the beauty of it
then
finally right here we just add
a toy from a happy meal right in there
just put it in there
close it up and that is ready to go we
call this the conan all right
now oh the happy guy came out all we
have to do now is send it to you lance
that's right i'm going to send this
sandwich to you unfortunately all i have
is this fedex tube
help me out here blay
get this to you
get it in there this is coming to you
lance we're going to mail this to you
i can't afford to do overnight so it's
going to take
probably about two weeks but this is
coming your way lance if you have other
questions send them facebook.com
teamcoco and i will answer your
questions
good enough just send that out